MALE SPEAKER: Good
afternoon and welcome to
Talks at Google in
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure
to introduce science writer Sam
Kean.
As you know, no one brings in
more speakers on neuroscience
than this office.
Last Halloween, Tim
Verstynen spoke eloquently
on the neuroscience
of the zombie brain,
and today Sam will
discuss his newest book,
"The Tale of the
Dueling Neurosurgeons:
The History of the
Human Brain as Revealed
by True Stories of Trauma,
Madness, and Recovery."
In this book he shows
how neuroscience
developed over the centuries.
The old fashioned way scientists
would wait for misfortune
to strike in the form
of strokes, seizures,
infectious diseases,
horrendous accidents,
and see how the victims coped.
Speaking of accidents,
are there any descendants
of the French house
of Valois here today?
Show of hands?
OK.
Because the book's
title refers to what
happened after King
Henri II or Henry II
was lanced through the skull
during a joust in 1559.
Sam has written two previous
books, "The Disappearing Spoon:
And Other True Tales
of Madness, Love,
and the History of the
World from the Periodic
Table of the Elements,"
and "The Violinist's Thumb:
And Other Lost Tales of
Love, War, and Genius
as Written by Our Genetic Code."
Please join me in
welcoming Sam Kean.
SAM KEAN: Well hello, everyone.
Thank you all for joining
me this afternoon.
So people often
want to know what
inspired you to write a book.
And with this book
what inspired me
was doubt, or
skepticism, or mistrust,
whatever you want to call it.
Because a few years
ago I was reading
about someone who
suffered a brain injury,
and his behavior changed in this
really drastic way after it.
And I was reading
this story and I just
said to myself, you
know, bull sugar.
I said, there's no way
that this story is true.
It's just-- his
behavior was too odd.
I just didn't believe it.
Anyway, I kind of
forgot about it.
And then I read about something
a few weeks later very similar.
A woman suffered a brain injury.
Her behavior changed in this
really specific, strange way
and I thought, baloney.
I thought, there's no way
that can possibly be true.
So I set out to try to
disapprove these stories
and I ended up, in the
end, proving myself wrong.
These stories were true.
But I realized that they offered
kind of an interesting insight
into the way the brain works.
So what kind of
stories were these?
Well, I'm sure we've all heard
stories of people getting
injured and then they
lose the ability to speak,
or their memory
goes on the blink,
or they're paralyzed in part of
their body, things like that.
So it wasn't stories like
that, because I'd already
heard things like that.
Instead these were
stories about things
they were very startlingly
specific talents
that people lost.
For instance, I think we
all know generally what
kind of animals are
in this picture here?
Even if we don't know
the genus and species,
we can generally
recognize what they are.
But if you get nicked in
the temporal lobe in one
specific spot--
the temporal lobe
is on the side of your brain.
You get nicked in one specific
spot, all knowledge of animals
can just disappear
out of your mind.
These people can still tell
plants apart just fine.
They can recognize different
people's faces no problem.
But elephants, dogs, raccoons,
turtles, whatever, they all
look exactly the same to them.
They cannot tell
these animals apart.
Or kind of the opposite
thing can happen.
Maybe some people can
recognize animals just fine,
but all knowledge of plants
just sort of-- poof--
disappears out of their mind.
And what's going on here
is that our ancestors way,
way back when, some people
were better than others
at recognising and
remembering certain animals,
certain plants,
things like that.
And it turns out the people who
were really good at remembering
animals, plants, and
could classify them--
that these animals
are good to eat,
these animals are
dangerous, these animals are
good companions.
Those people kind
of had an advantage
over the people who
were bad at recognizing,
telling other animals
apart, things like that.
And eventually this
sort of ability
to recognize animals and plants
got hard wired into our brain.
It gave those people
a big advantage.
But the downside of
having the hard wiring
is that if that spot of
the brain gets injured,
that knowledge
can just disappear
and you're going to
have a deficit suddenly.
So that's what kind of was
going on with these people.
Again, kind of giving an insight
into how the brain evolved,
a little bit about its history.
The other story
I heard I thought
was maybe even a
little stranger.
Again, we've all heard
stories about people who've
been injured in one
part of their brain
and suddenly they lose
the ability to speak.
They just can't form
words, can't get
sentences out of them.
But sometimes what's
actually going on
is that the language centers
of the brain are actually OK.
They're undamaged.
What's damaged is the wires that
connect the language centers
to the mouth, the teeth,
the tongue, and the lips.
So again, the
language center is OK.
It's that the wires sending
the information are broken.
But one thing you learn
about neuroscience
when you start reading
is that there's
a lot of different
ways for information
to move around in the brain.
There's a lot of back
alleys, a lot of detours,
things like that.
Information can go through
a lot of different routes.
So sometimes the
direct connection
is broken but there
are back alleys
that the information can take.
Specifically, there
are back alleys
that go from the
language centers
to the emotional
centers of the brain,
and from the emotional
centers they can still
access the teeth, the
tongue, and the lips.
So when you're talking
to these people
where the direct
connection's broken
but this back route through
the emotions is still there,
you try to engage
them in conversation,
they just can't
get the words out.
They're just
struggling to speak.
But if you provoke
them, you get them mad,
you start to rile
them up a little bit,
they can swear at you just fine.
They'll say you
beepity-beep-beep,
and then, you know, they'll
sort of grab their mouth
because in a lot of
cases they didn't even
realize that they
could swear like this.
It just sort of bubbles up
out of them unconsciously.
Another thing that can
happen, very similar,
is there are connections
sometimes between the language
centers, the parts of the
brain that process music,
and from there it can get
to the teeth, the tongue,
and the lips.
And with these people
they can't speak again
but they can sing
song lyrics just fine.
An example of this was
Gabrielle Giffords,
the Congresswoman from Arizona.
A few years ago after
she got shot in the head,
she lost the ability to
speak, but she could still
sing a lot of song lyrics.
She was singing songs like
"Girls Just Want to Have Fun."
And I don't know why Cindy
Lauper was the song that
ended up sticking in her
head, but she actually
re-learned,
re-taught herself how
to speak by practicing
singing these song lyrics over
and over again.
And I was sitting there thinking
to myself one day like, wow.
I bet you could write a whole
history of the brain just sort
of based on these
different injuries
and what each one teaches you
about how the brain works,
what that part does, et cetera.
And then sort of the
cartoon light bulb
went off over my head and
I said, oh boy, you know,
I should write a book like that.
That would be a lot of fun.
And so that's where
this book came from,
was trying to prove those
other stories wrong, but not
only proving that
they were correct
but finding out that it had
a lot of interesting things
to say about the
history of the brain.
Because until the
past few decades or so
there really only was one
way to study the brain.
You had to wait for injuries to
strike people and then see how
their minds changed afterward.
Sometimes these were tumors
or gun shots, lobotomies
that went wrong, rabies
infections, all these sorts
of different things.
And there were some really
miraculous tales of recovery
out there.
But if people's bodies
recovered, their minds didn't.
At least not quite.
Because there was often
something a little off,
something a little unusual
about the people afterward.
Some people started
lying incessantly,
some people lost
all fear of death,
parents suddenly couldn't
recognize their children
anymore.
But in each case it gave
a very important clue
about what that specific
area of the brain did.
And basically all of
the major breakthroughs
in the history of
neuroscience came about
because of these sorts of cases.
And stories are probably more
important to neuroscience
than maybe any other
scientific field out there.
So I'm happy to be able to share
a few of those stories with you
this afternoon.
So we're going to start with
something sort of visceral,
kind of a basic brain
function, and that is emotions.
So here's a picture of
something that, if you saw it--
or if you actually saw
this in real life--
it would probably
cause an emotion
to rise up inside of you.
So just a quick overview of
some of the emotional structures
in the brain.
And don't worry too much about
all the details, but just
a quick overview.
If a big tiger jumped
up in front of you
like this, first thing
that would happen,
obviously, is your
eyes, your ears,
your senses would take
in the information
and they would send it to a
structure in the center there
called the thalamus, the big
oval, the yellow oval there
in the middle.
The thalamus is
really a relay center.
It takes information
in and starts
sending it to other parts of
the brain for more processing.
One of the places it
sends the information
is to the hippocampus,
the long green thing
going around the outside.
I'll talk a little bit
more about that later,
but the hippocampus
is basically involved
with forming and
storing memories.
That's its basic role.
Another place the thalamus sends
information is to the amygdala.
The amygdala is
involved in processing
a lot of different emotions,
but its basic job is to say, OK,
so what?
There's something
in front of me.
I'm getting some information
about it, but so what?
Should I care about
this thing or not?
And in this case the amygdala
is going to say, OK, you know,
there's this big
cat in front of me.
It's growling.
It's starting to run at me.
It's probably something I
should care about right now.
So it's going to
send information
to another structure called the
hypothalamus, the purple thing
there.
And what the
hypothalamus does is
it's really kind
of the interaction
between the brain the body.
So the hypothalamus is going to
give you a shot of adrenaline.
It's going to make
you want to run away.
It's going to make you
want to do something
with that information.
So there's other parts
of the brain that
do get involved with
emotions, but that's
kind of a basic overview
of the limbic system,
kind of how the emotional
centers in the brain work.
But because these are
organic brain structures,
if you suffered damage
to one of these parts
this process can go awry.
And this story of one of these
emotional centers going awry
involves a woman who
was born in Iowa.
She was growing up there in the
1960s, and when she was young
she had perfectly normal
emotional responses.
In particular, she had a
perfectly normal fear response.
So for instance,
when she was young
she was at her
neighbor's house one day
and she remembered
a doberman came out
and it kind of cornered
her in the kitchen.
Her heart started pounding,
her throat went dry.
Pretty typical fear response.
But at about the
age of nine or ten
she came down with
the very rare disease
that ended up destroying both
of the amygdala in her brain.
She was left with what
her doctors described
as two black holes where
her amygdala should be.
And basically since that point
she has not felt a lick of fear
in her life.
And studies involving
this woman--
in the medical literature
she's known as SM.
I'm just going to call her
Sarah, just to kind of give her
a name.
But stories involving
Sarah are actually
kind of a hoot to read
about because they basically
involve scientists
trying to think up
ever-more-elaborate
ways to frighten her.
So for instance, one time
they decided, well, you know,
we're going to drive
her to this pet store.
We're going to expose her
to some spiders and snakes,
see how she reacts to that.
Now, on the drive to the
pet store Sarah was saying,
you know, I'm not
really that into snakes.
I don't think I'm going to like
this whole experience a lot.
But once she got
there she practically
jumped out of the car, ran
inside, grabbed the snake out
of the clerk's hand, let
it wrap itself around her.
She started playing with it.
You know, she was
having a good time.
And the part I remember reading
about that was really startling
was that the snake--
it was, like,
flicking its tongue at her.
And every time it tried to
flick its tongue at her,
Sarah was trying to grab
on to the snake's tongue,
like trying to time
it and grab it.
And I admit, I'm
no reptile expert,
but I'm pretty
sure snakes do not
like having their tongues
grabbed like that.
They don't respond well to that.
But she didn't care.
She was having fun and just
playing with this snake.
Another thing they
tried to do is
they tried to bring
to this haunted house.
It was in an old lunatic asylum.
There were a lot of dark corners
and creaking floorboards,
pretty spooky.
They matched her up with five
other women about her age
as kind of a control
group and they sent her
through this haunted house
to see what would happen.
And the other women, they were
kind of ducking their eyes,
they would scream
every once in a while.
You know, pretty typical
responses in a haunted house.
But Sarah didn't care.
Sarah would look at
in and kind of go, eh,
and then kind of wander
ahead, kind of wandering into
places she shouldn't have been,
poking her nose into areas.
And toward the end of the
trip through the haunted house
this monster jumped out.
It was an actor in a
costume, obviously.
But a monster jumped
out and said, rawr,
and tried to scare her.
And Sarah didn't blink, she
just kind of looked at it.
But she got kind of
curious because it
had kind of this bloody
goo on the side of its mask
and she wanted to know
what it felt like,
so she started walking
toward the monster.
Then she kind of lunged at it.
And she actually ended
up scaring the monster,
because he didn't expect
to get backed down
into a corner in this
little haunted house.
So every test they would
run her through they
could not find any
situation where she looked
like she was feeling fear.
But they want to be good
scientists about this
so they said, well, let's
explore some other things.
One thing they wanted
to make sure of-- she's
obviously not showing fear,
but maybe she's just sort of
blunted to all emotions.
Maybe fear is just
an obvious one,
but maybe she really can't
feel any emotions very well.
So what they did is they started
showing her a bunch of movie
clips, you know, happy,
sad, disgusting scenes,
seeing how she reacted.
And it turns out
Sarah was experiencing
these other emotions just fine.
In fact, she was sort
of overly-emotional
in these other cases.
She was happy at the right
times, sat at the right times,
disgusted at other
times, but fear--
she just wasn't feeling fear.
And that's kind of the
first big insight you
can get from studying
people like Sarah,
is that, for whatever
reason, you really
need an amygdala to feel fear.
The amygdala is involved
in processing lots
of different emotions,
but the other emotions
can go on one of
those back alleys.
They can take one of
those detours in the brain
and still get processed
in other ways.
But for some reason
the amygdala-- or fear,
I should say-- really
needs the amygdala.
It really has to
be intact or you're
going to struggle with
the fear response.
So again, that's
kind of a big insight
we can get that we wouldn't
have gotten unless they'd
suffered damage to the
amygdala and just sort of taken
it offline like that.
Another thing these
scientists wanted
to make sure of
though was-- you know,
these were all sort of
contrived situations
that they were putting Sarah in.
Nothing much is going to
happen at the haunted house.
It's pretty safe in reality.
And even at the pet
store with the snakes
there was a clerk there,
there were people there,
they weren't giving her the most
poisonous snakes or anything.
Like, she was probably
not in that much danger.
So they wanted to know were
there any situations in real
life were she actually should
have felt fear but she just
didn't?
And it turns out there was
one of these incidents, what
I call the Knife Incident.
So Sarah was in her
home town one day.
She was walking home through
the dark-- already a bad idea--
and she decides he's going to
cut through this unlit park.
So she's walking through
there and she sees this man
on a bench off to the side.
She later described him as
looking really drugged out.
The man noticed her
and he called out.
He said, hey, come over here.
So Sarah said, OK.
And she walked right over
to where this man was.
Immediately he jumped
up, he had a knife,
he spun her around and held
the knife to her throat.
So they later asked
her, you know,
what was going through your
mind at this moment when
you had the knife at
your throat like this?
And she remembered thinking
it was kind of inconvenience
that he'd done this and
she was a little angry,
like, she was going to
be late getting home now.
But, you know, the things
that we would fear, like,
oh my god I'm going to
die-- those things just
weren't going through her head.
She wasn't happy, but
she wasn't scared either.
She just wasn't
getting this response.
And after a minute
or two the man
noticed she wasn't, like,
panicking, struggling,
or anything and
Sarah said to him,
God's angels are
going to protect me.
And then after that the man
got a little weirded out
and he pulled the knife away
and just kind of backed off.
And instead of running,
sprinting for her life,
Sarah just kind to brushed
herself off and just kept
going through the park.
Next day she went right back
to the park, cut right back
through the park again.
She really was incapable
of feeling fear even
in these really dire,
serious situations.
And overall, in looking,
studying the behavior of Sarah
and other people
like her, I think
probably the biggest
insight we can get into this
is that fear really involves
two steps in the brain.
There's the part where we focus
our attention on something,
and then, a split-second
later, we feel fear.
Our heart starts pounding,
we get a shot of adrenaline,
we run away, we start to
fight, we do something.
And in most of us these
things happen, these two steps
happen so quickly
we really don't
differentiate between them.
We notice it, we
lock our attention on
and then immediately
we're afraid.
But in Sarah,
these steps-- we're
able to tease them apart
because she was still
getting the first step.
She was locking her
attention onto things.
Because if you remember
at the snake store
or at the haunted
house, it's not
like she was just
indifferent to these things
where she was like, OK,
a snake or a monster,
she was fascinated
with these things
and she was really locking her
attention onto these things.
Which is important if
you think about it,
because our ancestors
way back when--
if a snake went slithering
through the grass
or something like that
they wanted to make sure
they paid close
attention to that.
You don't want to
find a deadly snake
and then get distracted by a
monkey or a cloud or something
like that.
You really want to pay
close attention to it.
But because of her
amygdala damage
Sarah wasn't getting
the second step,
which was to get the
heck out of there
or start running or
something like that.
So again, we really aren't able
to tease these two steps apart
unless we see people like
this with brain damage.
And overall, I think
that there's even
kind of a more interesting
and important lesson there,
and that-- excuse me.
And that is, we normally
think about emotions
and logical thinking
or reasoning
as being kind of
separate in the brain.
In fact, if anything
we think about emotions
as kind of disrupting
our ability to reason.
But one of the big insights in
the past about 30 or so years
of neuroscience is
that emotions really
do play a very important
role in every day reasoning.
They really, really
are important.
And in fact, when
you start to look
at cases of people like
Sarah or other people
that I talk about
in the book that
do have emotional
problems-- damage
to the emotional
systems-- they behave
in really strange,
really irrational ways.
In fact, it's the
lack of emotion
that's starting to
make them behave
in these really odd ways.
So it's not so much that reason
and emotion are different
or they're kind of
opposed, but emotion really
plays into reason.
And again, that's not
how we normally think
about how our brain works.
But again, it's a
really important lesson
for the past three decades
or so of neuroscience.
And emotion really is
fundamental to a lot
of different thinking
in the brain,
including how our
logical brain works.
And it's thanks to
people like Sarah
we've gotten these insights.
So again, now with
something pretty basic,
pretty visceral- emotions.
For the next part
of the talk I want
to jump to something
a little higher-level
and talk a little bit about
identity, personal identity.
And I'm going to talk about
a few different stories here
involving a few
different people,
and really talk about how
brain damage-- what it
does to your sense of identity.
So the first story involves
this man right here,
a man by the name
of Clive Wearing.
So he was involved in the
classical music scene in London
in the late '70s, early 1980s.
A very well known conductor, did
some writing music on his own.
When the BBC needed to broadcast
Charles and Diana's, wedding
for instance, Clive was
the one they called on
to arrange the score
for the broadcaster.
So very well known,
very well-connected.
But in about 1985 or so Clive
came down with what he thought
was a flu.
You know, he was feeling achy,
feeling kind of run down.
Doctor went to visit him and
said, OK, just get some fluids,
get some rest.
But he just wasn't
getting better.
For instance, about
eight or ten days in he
wondered outside once and
couldn't remember where he was.
He got in a taxi, couldn't
remember his address,
they had to drop him off
at the police station
and his wife had to
come get him there.
And then finally, about 16 days
into this illness, they drug
Clive to the hospital.
And it turns out he didn't
have the flu at all.
He had an infection
in his brain.
And the infection was what's
called the herpes virus.
It's the same virus
that causes cold sores.
And actually it's the same virus
that the people I mentioned
at the beginning of
the talk who couldn't
recognize animals and plants.
They all suffered from an
infection of the herpes virus
as well.
And I don't mean to throw
any panic into anyone
in the audience, but
every once in a while
one of these cold sore
viruses will go rogue
and will start to migrate up
the olfactory nerve, the smell
nerve.
It will get inside the
brain, and once it gets there
it just starts
destroying things.
It just wreaks havoc
inside the brain.
Where Clive suffered
a lot of damage
especially was to
his limbic system.
In particular, his hippocampus,
which was the structure
I mentioned earlier
as very involved
with forming and
storing memories.
So when Clive woke up
he was an amnesiac.
Now, just to explain a
little bit about amnesia.
The kind of amnesia you see
in neuroscience patients
like Clive-- it's
not like quite what
you see in the movies
or something like that.
They don't forget their
names, they actually
retain a lot of muscle memories,
motor memories, riding a bike,
playing the piano.
Usually you retain those things.
And you might even retain some
information from your past.
It's pretty spotty, but maybe
you'll remember, you know,
like the rules to a card
game or something like that.
There's little bits there.
But you do lose
most of your past.
And what you really
loose is you lose
the ability to form new
memories going forward.
And in fact, Clive suffered
from the worst case of amnesia
that the neuroscientific
community had ever seen.
For instance, he would
be talking with someone
and they might have, like, a
blue shirt on or something,
and he would look away from
them and he would look back
and their shirt would seem to
be a different color because he
couldn't remember what color
their shirt was before.
Or he'd be playing solitaire
or something and he would blink
and the cards would seem to have
rearranged themselves suddenly.
That's how short-term
his memory was at first.
It couldn't even last from
the beginning of a blink
to the end of a blink.
And what this ended up doing is
it really affected-- obviously
not only Clive's
day-to-day life,
but it started bringing up
an unusual symptom in that it
started affecting what he
called his consciousness
or his ability to be awake in
that the way he interpreted
what was going on is he thought
that he just become conscious
for the first time.
It was like the past had not
even existed before and now
he had just sprung into being.
And as you can imagine, this
was kind of an exciting moment
for Clive in that,
if you had just
become awake right now
for the very first time,
you'd be really excited.
Like, wow, I've just been
given this gift of life.
This is amazing.
And what he would
do is he would try
to record this moment in his
diary whenever it happened.
He would see his
diary, he would grab it
and he would write 8:31, now
I am really, completely awake.
9:06, now I am perfectly,
overwhelmingly awake.
9:34, Now I am superlatively,
actually awake.
He was very good with
adverbs, Clive was.
And if he didn't have
his diary lying around he
would write something
on the wall,
he would write something
on the furniture just
to record this
momentous occasion.
But every time he
would get his diary
back he would open it to the
fresh page and-- you know,
he has dozens of diaries just
filled with pages like this--
but he would find the
latest fresh page,
he would see the old entry
there and he would say, well,
that entry's clearly
false because now
is the first time I'm awake.
So he would cross
the old entry out,
write the new entry in there.
10 minutes later he would
have the exact same epiphany.
He would grab his diary,
he would open it up
and he would say, well, that
last entry is clearly false
because now I'm awake
for the very first time.
Cross the old entry out,
write the new entry in there.
As I said, he has
dozens of diaries
just filled with page after
page of entries like this.
And this isn't normal for people
with even very severe amnesia.
They know there's
something wrong.
They know they can't
remember things,
but they don't think they've
just become conscious
for the very first time.
It's a very unusual symptom.
So the obviously question is,
why is this happening to Clive?
What about his brain damage
is causing this to happen?
And neuroscientists
don't quite know yet.
They'll probably have to
wait until he passes away--
he's still alive now--
and look at his brain
to try to figure
out what's going on.
But one thing we can say
from Clive and other patients
like him is that-- we can
say two things, actually.
One, we know that
it's not like there's
a little consciousness
parked in your brain
and if that part gets damaged
then your consciousness
goes on the blink.
Consciousness is a
brain-wide phenomenon.
There's a lot of different
parts of the brain involved
with consciousness, which is
why we've never quite seen
this symptom before.
We probably haven't seen someone
with the exact brain damage
that Clive has.
So again, it's a brain-wide
thing, a system-wide thing.
You can't just be looking
at individual parts here.
That's really where the
future of neuroscience
is going, is looking not
just at individual parts
but whole systems and
how they're interacting
in the brain overall.
But I think the second
thing we can get out
of this-- excuse me-- is in
some ways even more interesting.
And that is, despite
all of the problems
that Clive is having, he
never really lost a sense
of personal identity, in that
he knows who he is deep down.
In fact, if you put Clive
in front of the piano,
ask him to start
playing or something,
he can start playing music.
He can, in fact, sight
read music just fine.
Because, as I
mentioned, sight reading
is really more of a muscle
memory, a motor memory,
than it is an explicit
conscious memory.
So Clive will sit down
and he'll start playing.
But something
unusual happens when
he starts playing
in that he starts
to feel like himself again.
He feels like the old Clive.
Something about the music, about
the momentum, the phrasing,
something about it allows
him to tap into his old self.
As soon as he stops playing
it all kind of falls apart
and he's sort of lost again.
But for those few
minutes at least
he feels like himself again.
And he gets glimpses of
this in other moments too.
When he meets his wife
again, for instance.
She doesn't live with him,
he's at an assisted nursing
facility.
But every time she comes over
he jumps up for joy because this
happened to him when
he was fairly newlywed
and he still has kind of
that puppy love for her.
And he can still tap into that
every single time he sees her.
And she admits it gets kind
of hard sometimes-- you know,
fake enthusiasm for the 10,000
reunion when she comes over.
But again, it's still
something deep inside him
that he's able to tap into.
His personal identity is
still there on some level.
And the next story I'm
going to talk about I think
gets at this idea of personal
identity even better.
So this story involves a woman
who was living a few hours
outside of Vancouver in
about 2005 when she found out
that she was pregnant, found
out she was going to have twins.
And so she was kind
of excited about this,
but in one of the ultrasound
visits they said, we're sorry,
we have some bad news.
Your twins are
conjoined-- what used
to be called Siamese twins.
But she decided she was
going to have the children,
she was going to
bring them to term.
And as you can
see in the picture
here the babies were actually
conjoined at the head.
They had a Siamese brain.
And I should say that the
two children-- they're
Krista and Tatiana-- they
are still alive today.
They're fairly healthy, fairly
happy, they're in school.
Things turned out about as well
as they could have for them.
But because they do
have this Siamese brain
they show some very unusual,
very interesting behavior.
Specifically, the part of
their brain that's connected
is a structure
called the thalamus.
I mentioned the thalamus
before as a relay center
for the brain.
So what it does is
it takes information
in from your senses, from
your eyes, your ears,
your mouth-- excuse
me-- your mouth,
and it relays it to
different parts of the brain.
So because they share a thalamus
they share sensory information
on some level.
So what does that mean?
Well, if one of the girls is
taking a sip on a cup of juice
the other girl can taste
the juice in her mouth.
Or if you tickle
one of the girls,
the other girl will
start to laugh.
If you give one of them a
shot at the doctor's office
the other will grab
her arm in pain.
They fall asleep together,
they maybe even dream together.
And so the obvious
question is, wow,
are they two individual
people or is this somehow one
person connected together?
How would you even ask-- go
about answering that question?
And it's a little ambiguous.
We don't quite know
yet, but I think
a lot of the evidence
points to them
being two individual people.
For instance, one thing
that the girls tend
to do when they meet somebody
new is they'll walk up to them
and one of them will say
something like, I am just me.
And it's kind of a
strange thing to say.
Like, we wouldn't go
up to just somebody
and start saying
something like that.
That seems kind of obvious.
But it seems like they
have some sort of instinct
where they want to assert this.
They want to say this to kind
of differentiate themselves.
So again, they're kind of
asserting their independence
from each other.
Another thing is that they have
distinct likes and dislikes.
For instance, one of the
girls happens to like ketchup.
She loves ketchup on her hot
dogs on her fries, whatever.
Unfortunately her sister
thinks ketchup is disgusting
and ends up scraping
at her tongue
whenever her sister eats it.
And it's kind of an
amusing anecdote,
but it is important
in that they're
getting very similar
sensory information
but they're reacting to
it in a distinct way.
So they're getting
the same inputs
but they're having
different experiences,
different reactions.
And I think that goes a long
way in showing that they're not
the same person.
Something different is
going on in their reaction
to this very similar
thing, to this ketchup.
And the last anecdote I think
maybe is even the best example.
Someone was watching
them one day
and they were at a
fast food restaurant.
And, you know, they're kids.
It had been a long day, they
start to snip at each other,
they start fighting,
they're pushing each other,
calling names.
Finally one of the
girls got sick of it.
She reached out, she slapped
her sister in the face,
and then grabbed
her own face in pain
because it hurt her to do that.
So maybe that's a
good lesson for kids.
Don't hit your
siblings like that.
But again, it kind
of goes to show
that, in this really heated
moment when she was just
lashing out, if she had thought
of herself-- she wouldn't have
lashed out at someone she
thought was identical with her.
Like, you don't start slapping
yourself when you get mad.
You want to hit other people.
You slap other people.
So in this
instinctive moment she
was kind of defining her
sister as a different person.
And in both of these cases, with
Clive and with these two girls,
again what I really
want emphasize
is that, despite their
unusual brain structure--
or in Clive's case a lot of
the damage to his brain--
even despite the fact
that his consciousness was
going on the blink
he still retained
a sense of personal identity.
And that's something I
found in story after story
throughout the book, that the
sense of personal identity
is something that's really,
really hard to dislodge.
It's not always at the surface.
It can be buried sometimes
but it almost never, ever
disappears in people.
You can still get
at it at some level.
And there's something kind of
reassuring in that, I think,
that even if we were to
suffer kind of this really
drastic brain damage we probably
wouldn't lose a sense of who
we are deep, deep down.
And throughout the book, I
talk about stories from people
from all walks of
life, people who
are very famous
like Woodrow Wilson
and the neurological
disorders he suffered
from while he was in office.
People like Dostoevsky-- you
know, the flashes of God he
would see when he was
getting ready to write.
Things like that.
Or there were stories of very
lowly, normal, everyday people
like Phineas Gage, that railroad
worker who had this spike blown
through the top of his head.
Probably the most
misunderstood man
in the history of neuroscience.
Most of the people
though are more
like Phineas Gage in that
they were just normal,
everyday people who
suffered something drastic
and then their lives changed.
They became sort of a
martyr to neuroscience
through no choice of their
own and became kind of famous
in the annals of neuroscience.
But one thing I realized
in going through this book
is, there's a tendency to
treat these people a little bit
like freaks sometimes.
You know, you see
them, you see whatever
outstanding neuroscientific
symptom they show
and you start to focus on that.
You get really excited
about that thing.
And really these cases are what
pushed neuroscience forward
for century after century.
But it's only really
when you start
to look at these
peoples' whole lives
that you really get a sense of
what an amazing organ the brain
is.
Because even when they suffer a
lot of damage, like Clive did,
they still retain a lot of
the things that we retain.
He loved music,
he loved his wife,
he had the same joys and
disappointments that we do,
he suffered the same
disappointments.
In 95 percent of
the ways his brain
worked exactly like ours do.
And even though
there's a tendency
to focus on that one
thing, when you step back
and look at how the
brain works overall
you really see what an
amazing, resilient organ it is.
And I started to think
about these people
a little bit like optical
illusions, in that you
can focus on the
one thing, you can
focus on the damage and
their outstanding symptoms,
but if you just look
at it a different way--
you're looking at the same thing
but you start to notice, wow,
how courageous they are, how
perseverant, how their brain is
resilient over time, the
way the brain compensates,
gets around these
sorts of damage.
You really start to see
what an incredible organ
it is when it starts to
recover in its day-to-day,
year-to-year,
lifetime-to-lifetime process.
And it's really how
I wanted the book
to grow from beginning
to end, as you
start to see more of these
tales of perseverance, courage,
recovery, things like that.
As I said before,
stories probably
mean more to neuroscience
than maybe any other field
out there.
Their really baked into
the core of neuroscience.
And above all, I
think what they help
us do is they help
us understand what
it means to be a human being.
So I'm happy I was able to share
a few of those stories with you
today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm happy to answer any
questions, if anyone has any?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
about-- I almost
think of it as a
hardware-software distinction.
You mentioned
resilience and the way
that things go through, like,
back alleys to accomplish
the same thing.
Isn't the fact that it's a back
alley just because they hadn't
needed to go that way before?
And it's almost like a default
configuration of the software
and an alternate path
would work just as well,
but maybe it's not as strong?
I don't have a-- I get a sense
from these kinds of stories
that there's a mentality
of the hardware determines
the behavior, the hardware
determines the capabilities.
But if somebody
loses the ability
to categorize animals
they can relearn
the ability to
categorize animals,
I presume, because they've
got the rest of their brain
available for that.
Could you speak to that at all?
SAM KEAN: Yeah.
One thing that-- so I
use the metaphor-- people
use the metaphor of
wiring for the brain.
And it's a good metaphor
in a lot of ways,
but it does miss something
in that a wire is just
sending a signal.
A wire doesn't really
change over time.
When you lay the wire
it's pretty much there
and it's going to do
what it does depending
on what's coming down.
Neurons are different from that
in that each neuron connects
to thousands of other neurons.
There are branches going
all over the place.
Sometimes though neurons
ignore information
coming from certain branches.
So the neuron is trying to send
a signal but the other neuron's
ignoring it.
So there are a lot of
these alternative pathways,
but information maybe
isn't going down them
unless something
happens, damage occurs.
In which case, the
neuron will learn
to start accepting
information from other areas.
So basically it's
like it's rewiring in
that the signal is going
in a different route,
but you're not actually laying
down new wires in the brain.
It's not like new
neurons are growing,
it's just that the information's
going along a different route.
So the wiring metaphor
is good up into a point
because wires don't
change their behavior.
They're not quite dynamic
in the way that neurons are.
AUDIENCE: In your
research for the book
did you discover any
brain injuries that
caused maybe not a disability
as much as maybe an advantage
to the person that
received the injury?
Like a different way of thinking
about the injury that maybe
propelled them, made
them good at math
or better at art or
anything like that?
SAM KEAN: Yeah.
There are stories out.
There are people who didn't
care a whistle about poetry
or painting before, they
suffer a brain injury
and all of a sudden they're
obsessed with painting,
they love poetry suddenly.
They get it in a way that they
never really got it before.
Well, there was a story
about a year or so ago now
of a guy who had a brain
injury and he suddenly
became very good at math.
You know, he was sort of
like this prodigy suddenly.
I don't think he'd been
terrible at math before,
but not nearly as good
as he was suddenly.
So you do see cases like
this where people suddenly
get a talent.
And they do think--
it's sort of rude
to refer to them
as idiot savants--
people who have one ability,
like the ability to just hear
music and play it instantly.
In a lot of cases these
people do have damage
to the left side of their
brain which is usually
the dominant, controlling side.
And what they think is that,
because the dominant side isn't
working or isn't
dominating the way
it normally is, that the sort
of stereotypical right brain
talents have a chance
to flower a little bit.
So you do see cases
where damage or an injury
allows a talent to come out in
a way that wouldn't have before.
What almost always happens
though is the people lose
other abilities.
I have never seen-- I've
never seen a case of someone
suffering an injury,
just getting a talent,
and nothing else
happens to them.
Usually they suffer a lot
of their day-to-day life
and this is just one
small compensation
for all the other things
that have happened.
AUDIENCE: Lately
I've been hearing
a lot about neural
plasticity and things
like people's behavior or
people's personalities,
how our brain and our
minds and our personalities
aren't necessarily hardwired
and baked in forever,
but certain techniques,
certain practices
can change the way we
see things and the way we
react to things, the way we
behave and so on and so forth.
So if neuroplasticity
is a thing and really it
seems to be working-- at
least that's what I'm reading,
a lot of psychology-- you
know, treatments and research
is centered around it.
How is that connected to an
actual, physical brain injury?
Like, why wouldn't the brain
use the neuroplasticity
to compensate for
a physical ailment?
You see what I mean?
SAM KEAN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So if
behaviors can change
why can't skills and memory
and knowledge change over time?
SAM KEAN: Well, our knowledge
and our skills and our memory
are changing.
That's one thing
that we do sort of
retain the ability-- we know
that our memories change
over time.
That's one thing that
the adult brain can do.
The adult brain is not as
good as the brain of children.
It's not as plastic
as a child's brain.
And now we all know,
obviously, children
can pick up skills, languages,
whatever, very, very quickly.
Much more quickly
than adults can.
So neuroplasticity does occur.
We can sort of rewire what's
going on in our brains.
It that in the adult brain
it takes a lot more work,
a lot more practice.
You just have to really
go over it over and over,
really labor, really work
because the brain just
isn't as plastic as that age.
You lose the ability to
start sending information
down alternative
routes, for neurons
to sort of talk to their
neighbors in different ways.
You just lose that ability.
And overall it's
probably a good thing
because if our brains
were too plastic
you would learn something
and then the next day you
would just forget it.
It would kind of go
out of your brain,
or you would lose the ability to
ride a bike because you hadn't
ridden one in five years
and your brain would say,
I'll just get rid of that.
Like, you just dump
the information.
So you don't want
infinite plasticity.
That would be bad.
But we do know that we can
rewire it to some extent.
Not to an infinite
degree, because there's
some things that you probably
just won't be able to pick up,
even if you practice
them a lot, just
depending on your brain, your
temperament, things like that.
So you can rewire yourself to
some degree, but I don't know.
I think it remains an open
question, how far you can go.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you're saying that if the
same physical injury happens
to a child versus
an adult, the child
will have a much better chance
of regaining the ability
that he or she lost?
SAM KEAN: Yeah, vastly.
Yeah.
You see stories of
children who-- they open up
their-- adults, I should say.
They open up their brain
or they look at their brain
and there's a big hole or
something there and say, what?
You don't have this
part of your brain.
And they're going, well--
They just-- their brain
got around it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I loved "The
Disappearing Spoon."
SAM KEAN: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I still
recommend this book,
like, it's probably one
of my favorite books
in the last decade.
SAM KEAN: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell me
what are you writing about,
what are you working on now?
Because I'm going
to read anything
you read and I'm just excited.
SAM KEAN: So I'm
working on a book now.
I don't know-- we haven't nailed
down the publication date yet,
but it's going to
be called something
like "Caesar's Last Breath."
Basically the idea is,
you take a deep breath.
You inhale all these gases,
obviously nitrogen, oxygen,
things like that.
But you also inhale a
lot of refrigerants,
you inhale
pollutants, you inhale
little bits of anesthesia.
You inhale all these
different gases, some of them
industrial, some of the natural,
some of them from volcanoes,
whatever.
And basically if you look at all
the different gases you inhale
every single time you
can kind of reconstruct
the whole history of the world,
where everything came from,
all the stages that human
beings went through,
where we're going in the
future, every single time
you take a breath.
All of these stages are kind
of washing through your lungs.
So it's kind of taking the
gases and kind of jumping off
from there into the
time Einstein tried
to build a refrigerator,
or to Roswell, or back
to our early volcano
days, things like that.
So "Caesar's Last Breath"--
kind of the history of the world
in every breath.
Well, thank you everyone.
I appreciate it.
I'm happy to sign books,
too, if you want that.
[APPLAUSE]